Hello and welcome to Python Bytes where we deliver Python news and headlines directly to your earbuds. This is episode 78 recorded May 17th
2018 I'm Michael Kennedy and I'm Brian Harkin and we have a special guest with us here. Don't we Brian? Yeah. Yeah. Hey Kojo
Yeah, we have Kojo Itarisa here on the show. Thank you for coming and joining us. No problem. Thank you for having me
Yeah, it's really great. All three of us got to have a wonderful time at PyCon didn't we? Yes, we did
Oh my goodness. So I'm totally going to recap on that first. But let's just say thanks to
Data Dog. This episode is brought to you by Data Dog. Check them out at pythonbytes.fm/datadog.
They were at PyCon. And so were all we, all of us. In fact, Kojo, you and I, we kind of
jumped into the deep end, like right at the beginning. I was sort of standing around outside
and you were, you walked in this room and, you know, just, it was like, hey, we don't
have enough people to or enough room to give this welcome speech to all the newcomers.
So you and I ended up giving the welcome speech right to a second group.
You and I and Trey Hunter ended up sort of as the impromptu host of that.
Yeah, first it was Trey Hunter.
I mean, I saw you walking like, hey, you need to come up to the front and be part of this.
So that was really awesome.
Thanks for doing that with me.
Brian, what was your favorite thing about PyCon?
I guess seeing everybody that I only know from their little tiny circle icon on Twitter
and being able to see him in person and chat.
I was actually often surprised because I didn't recognize somebody,
even though I see their little picture all the time.
Well, you know how, how many tiny pixels it's like,
like a 64 by 64 sort of thing, right? Yeah. Yeah. Pretty funny.
Pretty funny. So, Kojo, how about you? Favorite thing at PyCon?
I think for me,
my favorite thing about PyCon was just getting a chance to get caught up with
folks,
getting a chance to get caught up with people that I already know,
then also getting a chance to meet new people.
And I think the sort of the impromptu,
impromptu leading of the new attendee session was nice
because it made it easier to meet new people.
So.
- Yeah, that was really nice
because the people felt more comfortable coming up
and speaking to you and me after that.
I think my favorite thing
was actually the live Python Bytes recording.
That was fun, right, Brian?
- Oh, that was a blast.
Yeah, it was really good.
We need to do that every year.
- I think I'm definitely planning on doing that again
every year.
I'm thinking about trying to actually propose that.
It's like an official part, an official activity
that is part of some of these conferences like PyCascades
or maybe PyCon or something.
But if nothing else, certainly the open session was awesome.
And we'll talk more about that later.
But let's get to your first item, Brian.
Somebody forgot an else statement, is that what happened?
- Yeah, well, there's more else statements in Python
that you might not know about.
Like I read this and I'm like,
oh yeah, I forgot about these.
Anyway, so both for, I mean, you can use else clauses
for if statements, everybody knows that.
But for and while loops also have if statement or else clauses.
Their while and for loops are loops.
And if they complete all the way through,
then the else clause gets run.
And there's a little article to describe that,
that we've linked to called the forgotten optional else in Python loops.
But I wanted to highlight it because often I forget about it.
The thinking around this is if you're using a loop to search for something
or search for different things,
and you want to bail out if you find something,
one of the ways is to mark a flag to say,
"Hey, I found this thing."
But you don't need a flag if you take advantage of the else clause.
So I just wanted to highlight that and remind everybody.
Yeah, so both the for and while loops,
and these definitely seemed a little bit funky to me
when I learned about it.
I'm like, "Wait, the while loop has an else clause?"
My mind is melting.
Kojo, did you interact with these?
Have you ever used an else clause on a loop?
On a for loop, I don't know that I have actually.
Yeah, I always look at them and wonder why they're there.
I mean, it's pretty cool to know about them.
I feel like this is one of those things that you could get asked in a job interview.
Like, "Oh, what does the else clause do?"
Like, "Wait, there's an else clause? How interesting."
So this is, I would say this is one of the less used part,
major pieces of syntax in the language for sure.
I would definitely, since I know a lot of people don't know about them,
if I was going to use them, I'd probably add a comment there to say,
"Hey, if we don't find the things, then we do this stuff."
- It's interesting.
It's definitely like one of these sort of Pythonic things
that is not necessarily obvious, right?
It's kind of like self-contradictory in that sense.
Yeah, yeah, pretty interesting.
All right, Kojo, you found some pretty cool stuff
with some libraries and dependencies, right?
Tell us about those.
- I got exposed to this,
really, I think on the last day of PyCon.
There's a website called libraries.io,
and what it does is it lets you
not only find different packages,
So like PyPy will let you find a number of different packages.
But what libraries.io does is it will let you find dependencies based on packages.
So if you go to libraries.io, you search for a certain package,
and then you can see what other packages that package depends on.
And so it's an interesting way to sort of see, to find out,
like if you're building a project, what things are you depending on?
And then maybe what things are those things depending on that you might not have been aware of?
And it will also point out like versions and that sort of thing.
So you can drill down fairly deep into it.
I think the person who introduced it to me
was pointing out that, I can't remember the package now,
but there's a certain package that depends on Twine,
which is the packaging tool,
but it depends on an older version of Twine.
And so on version of Twine,
this is like say maybe like a year or so old.
And so you can find that kind of information.
And so I thought that was interesting.
And then along with that,
libraries.io is run by a site that is called Tidelift
that is looking to try to help bring
some financial support into open source software.
I haven't had a chance to look into that in great detail,
but it's interesting how the two are connected.
- That's pretty interesting.
So it's almost like you can get consulting support agreements
for a package that you might wanna use.
It's kind of what it sounds like.
- Yeah, it seems that way.
Like I said, I haven't had a chance to dig into it
in a lot of detail.
So I focused a little more on libraries.io,
but I think with libraries.io, you can help determine,
okay, well, what packages might I need
or want consulting support on?
So what are the packages that my project depends on heavily
and at the same time might not be getting as much support
as I might want.
And so maybe I wanna focus my support dollars
on that particular package,
just maybe two or three levels down in the stack.
- Yeah, how interesting.
So it says they give maintainers and core teams
a platform and marketplace
for building sustainable business around their project.
I bet that resonates with a lot of folks
who are out there listening to the show.
- I know there's been a lot of work done,
a lot of people who have been looking into
how do we make open source projects sustainable
instead of just having to depend on volunteer work.
- I think the most straightforward way
that this has worked traditionally
is either a very small amount of donations or consulting.
If I work on say Flask, then maybe I could consult
on help people out who are doing large flask things.
But this looks like a nicer,
sort of more formal arrangement.
So yeah, I really, hopefully that takes off.
That'd be great for people.
- Yeah, I think one of the things,
I was just playing with it.
One of the fun things about libraries.io is to look up,
if you're trying to use a new package
that you haven't used before, new library,
you can look to see who else is using it.
So you can maybe look at their source code
and see how they're using it.
- It's true, that's interesting.
- Oh, I see, other projects, right?
Like, here's some library, who else uses it?
Oh, look, request uses it.
So that must mean it's pretty stable or something like that.
- Or even just to look at code examples
of how they're using it.
- Yeah, very cool.
That's a good find, Kojo, thanks.
So either of you guys out there,
are you using type annotations,
type hints in your Python code?
- I am not.
But I had a brief discussion about them
when I was in Chicago a couple of weeks ago, so.
- Yeah, okay, Brian?
- Yeah, I'm starting to.
- Yeah, I think it's interesting.
I certainly don't go type crazy on the code that I write.
There's some obvious benefits
for like really large organizations.
And there's a great article I wanna link to
called "The Other Great Benefit of Python Type Annotations."
So they talk about things that are fairly straightforward.
You know, it's like we've had these type annotations
for a while, but maybe it's a little unclear
when to use them.
So it's good if you have some big project
you wanna somehow verify that things are working, right?
So you can employ like static code analysis, right?
with like mypy or a lot of things.
We've talked about some of the tooling previously,
Brian, that you could run across your code
and will like generate these
and then you can decide to incorporate them.
One idea I really like is sort of a twist
on an Uncle Bob quote,
who's sort of a software architect guy.
Says, "Cleaner code or the code that is self-documented
"is really great."
And traditionally people said,
well, we don't need a comment
when you can use a function or a variable
that's like well-named.
So maybe another way to look at it, another thing to say is,
like, we don't need a comment when you can specify,
to talk about the types,
when you could say specify type annotation.
So instead of just having a comment saying,
hey, this variable is such and such,
like a type annotation makes that sort of readability
super, super easy.
That's great.
And then obviously they're sort of optional, right?
This whole progressive typing or gradual typing thing
that they're doing is great.
So you can add it and it won't break your code,
but it also won't make it any faster, right?
Just use it where it's useful for you.
But this article says the final sort of straw
that was like the massive benefit for this guy,
and I agree with him, which is why I brought this in,
is around code completion.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Right, so like I've got some big application
and I typically put this sort of stuff on the boundaries
of one layer talking to another layer.
So I have the web app, the web app consumes
some sort of data access layer,
a logic layer that deals with services and data.
Like if you annotate just the stuff that is like public
from that data layer, it just flows through the rest of your application
and makes it super, super obvious, which I think that's pretty nice.
I was actually looking at an example of this last week of,
for instance, like if you've got a class that's,
like a new data class that has type annotations,
and you assign that to a variable,
and then you try to access elements of the variable, like PyCharm can like
help you, for instance, other editors as well, but PyCharm does those
hints and will tell you the types of the different
elements that you have access to.
Right. Or if you were to return some object from a method,
it might just have no completion, because who knows what that could be.
But if you annotate the return type, all of a sudden it like comes back to life.
Yeah. What editor do you use?
Primarily Sublime, but my co-workers,
I've had some co-workers use Sublime and some who use PyCharm.
So I've started using PyCharm more on the QA team where I work.
And so the other QA person tends to use PyCharm.
So I sort of go back and forth between the two, like on my personal machines.
I've got Sublime and on my work machine, I've got both.
And so I use them both in slightly different ways.
You're getting sucked into the PyCharm orbit.
Exactly. And I remember, I've also got things about it.
I also remember reading an article that you wrote about the benefit,
I think what the nine benefits of PyCharm.
Yeah, that was quite a while.
That really lays it out, right?
This code completion, one of them in this type annotations makes that better,
which I think is pretty awesome.
So, yeah, I just want to throw that out there.
Like, there's a whole sort of static code analysis stuff,
But this code completion, pretty major.
Alright, before we get to the next one, let me tell you all about Datadog
because they are major supporters of the show
and they really are helping keep it going.
So be sure to check them out.
So it's a monitoring solution that provides deep visibility into distributed applications.
So maybe you've got some microservices or got different Python applications
and you want to see how the database and the Python app
and Linux itself are interacting,
go check out Datadog.
So just a few minutes, you can investigate some bottlenecks in your code,
figure out where it's slow and make it better just reading a few dashboards.
So pretty cool.
So visualize your Python performance today.
Get started with a free trial of Datadog,
and they'll send you a cool Datadog t-shirt, which is awesome.
So just go to pythonbytes.fm/datadog.
Brian, when people create open source projects,
like, they usually do it because it's something that they love,
but then people start to depend on these projects,
And that can create some sort of animosity, right?
There's a lot of burnout in the open source space because of it, I think.
Definitely. We've seen a lot in the last couple of years of people,
you know, even taking a month off or six months off
to try to get away for some of it.
Or dropping projects trying to find other maintainers because
maintenance is kind of a hard problem.
This was something that was brought up, you said that from Brett Cannon,
I saw this talk Sunday morning for the Sunday morning keynote at PyCon.
And you said that he also gave it at PyCascades.
I don't know if it's exactly the same, but this general message, yes.
Yeah.
So the talk was called setting expectations for open source participation.
But it really is a discussion about kindness and paying for open source with kindness.
And he really talked about some, he gave some examples of basically every communication
you have with an open source project, even like a bug report, you need to realize that
you're taking somebody else's time out of their free time, the free time they could
be spending with their on their own projects or with their family.
And so be aware of that.
And he gave some examples of some good interactions and some bad interactions.
And then also some guidelines for how to communicate online.
It was pretty good.
I think the major sort of the main takeaway was most of these interactions are you asking for a favor?
And it sometimes doesn't seem that way, right? Like, so if I go to a project and say, here's a pull request, it's super small, all it does is add this one feature, it's like 10 lines, you can just read that. And it's no problem. But if the person decides to accept that, right, they're not you, they are responsible now for maintaining it.
but also documenting it, potentially testing it,
evolving it, right?
There's just so many layers.
It's like, hey, I did you such a nice favor.
Here's a puppy.
I got you a puppy.
And then if the person doesn't like it,
it's like, why don't they like the puppy?
That's so nice to give a puppy.
But you're really giving this thing
that you have to care for for a long time,
even if it's something as helpful as actually,
here's a pull request.
Yeah.
You're asking for work, for somebody else's work.
And we forget about that because we're used to like products where we can like,
complain about the Apple laptop keyboards and it's just okay.
But we probably ought to be nicer about that.
But when you like even complain about or tweet a negative thing about an open
source project or have a bug report where it's just like, I needed this to do this
thing and it's broken, you're really hitting somebody.
This is somebody's passion, somebody's spent a lot of time on,
and you're saying to them, "This is garbage."
So, yes, do bug reports, but do it in--
it's open source, it's a volunteer effort, so do it kindly.
Do it like you were asking your mother to do it or something like that.
And he presented it so well that I think
this sort of topic needs to be talked about more,
even within groups.
Like, I realized after listening to this and watching it
that I think it will help me even interact with my own team at work when it isn't volunteer,
it's people getting paid, but you still need to be respectful and considerate.
It's still basically a zero-sum game for their time and energy.
So by doing something, you were sort of taking a slice of that that maybe they didn't ask
you to take, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
Kojo, did you get to see this talk either in Vancouver or at the conference?
No, I saw it.
There was a similar talk at PyCon Canada in Montreal.
I saw it in Vancouver.
- Yeah, so have you had any interactions with folks
where you see people like giving up on open source projects
or other folks being unkind?
- I've seen a little bit of that,
maybe a little more than I would like.
I have seen people sort of complaining
about open source projects,
maybe not meeting their standards
or not being updated as quickly or as well as they would like.
I tend to be a little bit prickly about that kind of thing
because I think, so I'm relatively new
to software engineering,
And a lot of my exposure to software engineering practices
have been through the open source community
and through some of the larger open source projects.
And so I have an understanding that a lot of these things
that people depend on are being built by volunteers who
are doing it in their spare time.
And I've been fortunate enough to meet
a number of these people.
And so I know some of these people personally.
And so I guess it sort of helps humanize it
for me a little more.
So I try to sort of push back on those things.
Like, hey, you know what?
How much did you pay for this?
Or how much are you paying for this?
And also, you know, you can, if you want a problem fixed,
there's a well-documented process
for you to make a contribution
to help fix some of the problems for yourself.
And if you're someone who's a more experienced developer,
it's not that difficult for you to do.
- I think that's a really good point.
I guess the thing is, don't take it out on people.
Just vote with your feet.
If you see a project that has a hundred unresponded to PRs,
maybe that's not a real healthy project
and your choices are, don't be part of it,
or become a contributor,
but don't abuse the person who's already overwhelmed
and already has too much going on, right?
- Exactly.
- Yeah, yeah.
All right, so what's your next pick, Kojo?
- My pick sort of ties into that,
the idea of, you know,
these expectations for open source participation,
my thing is sort of focusing on
different Python community events.
And so, of course, you know,
we all just came from PyCon,
and one of the nice things about,
so there's PyCon itself,
but then for me, one of the nice things about it
was a chance to meet some of my,
to get back together with some of my friends
from the Python community.
Of course, we started off with, you know,
actually spending some time with you and with Trey
to help sort of welcome the first time attendees to PyCon,
sort of welcoming them into more active participation
in the Python community.
- Yeah, that was fun.
So let me ask you really quick about that
while you're on the topic.
Give me three really quick things people should know
to have like a better experience at PyCon
or local ones, maybe.
- So I would say one,
try to have some idea of why you're there.
Like, why are you attending PyCon?
Are you looking for a job?
Are you looking to hire people?
Are you looking to learn new things?
Are you looking to meet new folks?
That sort of thing.
And I think whether it's PyCon
or your local Python meetup,
it's sort of the same thing.
Like, you know, what are you going for just to learn
or just to meet other developers who work in Python
just like you do that kind of thing.
I think that's sort of the big thing.
And the other thing is to maybe,
with something like PyCon, try to manage your energy
because there are a lot of people at PyCon,
there's a lot going on.
you probably won't be able to go to every talk.
There's a temptation to try to consume
as much information as you can.
And then I think along with that managing your energy,
something that we pointed out to people
is to try to sort of, it's something like PyCon,
try to optimize for the human interactions,
like the open spaces and sort of the hallway track,
because the talks are awesome,
but they're all gonna be recorded
and then the videos will be available fairly quickly.
But the people that you meet
and the human interactions that you have,
or the cool things that happen in the open spaces,
those aren't going to be recorded.
So one of the things that I did at PyCon,
one of the open spaces I was in was hosted by Adafruit.
And so we got to sit down with some of the circuit boards
that were in our swag bags and write some code
and make LEDs light up and that sort of thing
and sit with people.
And so that's the thing that's,
I can't watch a video of that later.
I can't do that again later.
So I actually had that sort of direct interaction
with people.
So I think those would be sort of three things
to help guide people.
I really like to manage the energy
'cause I was done at the end.
Brian, how about you?
Wiped out at the end of PyCon?
- Very wiped out, yeah.
And I think that contributed to some of my,
kind of my funk and tiredness in the last few days.
- I'm still feeling it as well.
I'm feeling, it was totally worth it,
but I am wiped out.
All right, so the last one,
I wanna share a personal story with you
because we find all these things on the internet
and I think they're great,
but like every now and then it's like,
I just found this thing and it's so helped me
with this problem that I was running into
and I think it'll help a lot of people out there.
So I want to tell everyone about ngrok, N-G-R-O-K.
And that is a free with a premium upgrade sort of thing,
service that you can go and basically ignoring
all firewalls and all sorts of stuff,
expose basically local ports or local servers
on your computer.
So if I have say like a mobile device
and I have an app running on the mobile device
and I want to test the services,
but I'm like developing it,
Maybe I want to even debug like how that's working.
I could actually open, I could run this ngrok command.
It'll do an SSH tunnel that exposes, say,
my local dev port back to port 80 on the internet.
Then I go to that URL and hit something on my phone app,
maybe, and it like, I can step through it in PyCharm
on my local machine.
I think that is pretty darn awesome.
Or if you want to make, say, give access
to your Raspberry Pi so you can get into it
and call operations on it, test your chat bot.
The reason I was using it is I'm building
a set of applications, like proper compiled applications
that are offline for my courses.
So people can basically have offline access to the videos
and like sync up their account and then not depend upon
being on the web or on the internet, right?
So that's what I've been doing since I got back from PyCon,
is building that.
And I had been deploying stuff out to the internet
and I'd connect to it and test it,
and like, ah, that service isn't quite working.
and I was getting a little painful,
I'm like, why am I doing this?
'Cause one is on the Windows machine,
one is on my Mac, and it was easier to just do that, right?
Instead of, it wasn't on the same machine.
And so I'm like, I'm just gonna fire up ngrok,
and then I can actually do the same thing I showed you about.
I can actually step through as the Windows app
is interacting with the service
that ultimately makes its way back over HTTPS
onto my local machine.
Isn't that cool?
- Yeah, that's very cool.
- I got exposed to ngrok by a coworker,
and I hadn't seen it before, and I was like,
oh, well, that's, you know, that's pretty awesome.
- Yeah, the thing that I think is most useful
is so often, like I work in the web world, right?
So traditionally I had maybe made some changes
to the web app and then we might have like a scrum meeting
or like a quick sync up meeting,
like, hey, how's everybody doing?
And I'm not ready to publish what I've done
to the internet, to staging and mess everyone else up.
But I would still like to show people
and let them interact with it.
Instead of just doing like a screen share,
you can go, well, just go to this URL
and you can run it on my machine,
which is incredible for a quick iteration
of design and development.
- I just saw an interesting application for ngrok,
maybe like the weekend right before PyCon,
some friends who run a group here in town
called Girls Coding Club,
they were doing a sort of a tutorial session.
And so you got people sort of learning
how to build basic web applications.
I think they were using Rails,
but then you can use ngrok and then expose that
to the wider internet so that other people in the,
so people in the class can sort of,
can see each other's applications,
or you can send a link to a friend or what have you.
So it's also really good for tutorials, yeah.
- That is awesome, yeah, for classes, right?
So I've got a Slack channel for that group.
Everybody could ingrok their stuff and throw it in,
say, "Hey, mine's at randomaddress.ingrok.io."
Click on it and have a look, and you could,
without having to reconfigure that
on different people's servers.
I love it, and there's a totally reasonable free tier,
which is pretty awesome.
All right, well, that's it for our items this week.
I just have a few extra things I wanna share.
Brian, anything else you want to throw out there?
- I did on the plane coming back from PyCon,
I finally finished editing the interview with Trey Hunter.
So soon there will be a test and code podcast
with interview with Trey Hunter.
So that should be out soon.
- I saw that you're starting to publish
a little more frequently, which is great.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, I'm glad you're doing that.
So one of our listeners out there, Stephen, Stephen Howell.
Hello, Stephen.
Was kind enough to actually be live streaming our live,
well, semi-live in-audience recording
of Python Bytes last week.
That's pretty cool, right, Brian?
- That is neat.
Have you watched it?
- No, well, I watched some of it.
So he actually took the video
and it starts a little bit a ways in,
but he put it up on the internet on YouTube.
So if you guys were listening to the live episode last week
and you're like, well, what was that actually like?
Well, click the link at the bottom
and you'll be able to watch
a pretty high quality version of it, actually.
So that's pretty cool.
And then, you know, another thing I'd like to come back to
just really quick is, remember when we talked about
how easy it is to have a systemd daemon
as a Python application to basically implement
a systemd daemon in Python?
We talked about that in episode 54.
- Oh yeah, totally.
No, I don't remember that, but.
(laughing)
- So it turns out you basically have like six or seven lines
of configuration and then just an app
with like a while true loop.
It's insane.
And that's all you have to do to create like a
system start run forever sort of application in Python.
And it's really beautiful.
So I recently used that technique from Episode 54
to build a global series of video servers
throughout the world to do geolocated video
serving for all my courses to make that really much nicer.
So added one in Japan, Sao Paolo, and Mumbai this week.
So that'll make it a little better for people
out there listening.
But it's also a cool application of what
we talked about in Episode 54.
- Nice.
- Very interesting.
Yeah, very interesting.
- Incredibly simple.
I think more people probably would
to do it if they knew how easy it was. All right, guys. Well, that's all I got. Thank
you, Gojo, for being here. And Brian, thank you, as always, for making the show happen.
Thank you. Thank you for inviting me.
Yep. You bet. Bye, guys.
Thank you for listening to Python Bytes. Follow the show on Twitter via @PythonBytes. That's
Python Bytes as in B-Y-T-E-S. And get the full show notes at PythonBytes.fm. If you
have a news item you want featured, just visit PythonBytes.fm and send it our way. We're
always on the lookout for sharing something cool.
On behalf of myself and Brian Okken, this is Michael Kennedy.
Thank you for listening and sharing this podcast with your friends and colleagues.